imagine if you could gather the energy
from every star within a hundred million
light years from thousands of galaxies
each with billions of stars
imagine you could take this kind of
power and use it to fire the biggest
super weapon in the universe imagine the
damage you could do
it turns out you don't need to imagine
it
these exist and they're called gamma ray
bursts
but what are these cosmic snipers and
what happens if one takes a shot at
earth
[Music]
to understand gamma ray bursts we first
have to understand gamma rays
gamma rays are electromagnetic radiation
waves which carry energy just like
visible light
visible light is a tiny part of the
electromagnetic spectrum it's the part
your eyes can see at lower energies
there are radio waves microwaves and
infrared and at higher energies
ultraviolet x-rays and gamma rays
gamma rays are incredibly powerful
a single gamma ray photon is more
energetic than a million visible photons
combined
their high energy makes gamma rays a
form of ionizing radiation
meaning they are energetic enough to
break apart atomic bonds
this makes them dangerous to you and me
ionizing radiation disrupts the delicate
biochemical machinery that keeps us
alive like a nine millimeter bullet
through a clock
fortunately on earth the ozone layer
blocks gamma rays filtering them out
before they can harm us but if the
atmosphere blocks gamma rays from space
how were gamma-ray bursts or grbs from
space ever discovered
during the cold war the usa sent up spy
satellites which could detect gamma rays
from soviet nuclear tests in space
they didn't see any bombs but they did
observe faint bursts coming from space
lasting only a few seconds
to date this may be the only major
scientific discovery made by spy
satellites that we know about anyway
astronomers use telescopes that see
different kinds of light to make their
discoveries and these spy satellites
gave them a new pair of eyes they were a
mystery for 30 years but eventually we
discovered the source of a grb a galaxy
6 billion light years away
if a grb can be seen from such a
distance then it must be incredibly
energetic releasing more energy in a
second than the sun will in its entire
10 billion year lifetime making grbs the
brightest events in the universe
so where do they come from
grbs accompany some of the most violent
cataclysmic deaths in the universe and
the birth of black holes
there are two types of gamma ray burst
short and long and each has their own
source
long grbs last about a minute and
scientists think they are produced by
supernova when the core of a massive
star collapses to become a black hole
short grbs lasts a second and are
produced when two neutron stars in a
binary merge
over millions of years their orbits
decay by emitting gravitational waves
once they're close enough to touch they
crash and splash into each other forming
a black hole
both supernova and neutron star mergers
make the same thing black holes
surrounded by a magnetized disk of gas
left over from their parent stars in
these environments the rotation winds up
the magnetic field which funnels hot
jets of particles traveling at nearly
the speed of light
the gas in this funnel creates two tight
jets of high energy gamma rays like a
celestial laser gun so unlike other
cosmic explosions which spread out and
fade grbs stay focused and can be seen
from much further
any more detail would require too much
mathematics for a youtube video
the universe is full of these cosmic
snipers firing blindly and randomly into
the dark and they're hitting us all the
time
on average we detect one per day
fortunately most are harmless
all the bursts we have detected so far
originated outside the milky way too far
away to hurt us
but a nearby grb could be disastrous if
one goes off within a few light years of
us it would totally cook the surface of
the earth or at least the half that's
facing it
but even a more distant grb could still
end life on earth
and it wouldn't need to score a headshot
to kill us if originating from a few
thousand light years away it would be a
hundred light years wide by the time it
reaches us
washing over the solar system like a
tidal wave
again the ozone layer protects us but
it's better equipped to handle the
trickle of ultraviolet from the sun
a gamma ray burst would overwhelm it
leaving us exposed to deadly solar
radiation ozone takes years to replenish
itself by natural processes which is
more than enough time for the sun to
burn the earth sterile or at least to
kill most complex life
in fact this may have already happened
a grb has been suggested as one possible
cause of the ordovician extinction 450
million years ago that eradicated almost
85 percent of all marine species
although it's pretty much impossible to
prove
gamma ray bursts could even be one
reason we don't see life anywhere else
in the universe
they might be wiping clean huge chunks
of it on a regular basis
[Music]
it's been suggested that because of grbs
only 10 percent of all galaxies might be
hospitable to life similar to us
so are they going to kill us
probably not
in a galaxy like ours there may only be
one grb per millennia and to harm us
they must be close and directed at us
but since gamma rays travel at the speed
of light we won't no one is headed our
way until it arrives so there could
already be a grb on its way to kill us
all and we won't know it until it hits
us and we're dead
[Music]